c'est la fin de l'année et je me suis
dit que ça pourrait cool de revenir sur
ce que j'ai fait cette année déjà pour
vous livrer mon ressenti et aussi vous
faire découvrir à ceux qui n'ont pas
tout suivi c'est normal de patou suivre
vous inquiétez pas parce que pour moi
2014 ça a vraiment été une année
formidable en terme de rencontres de
projet tout ça bref c'est parti pendant
les vacances de noël j'ai eu l'idée de
faire une vidéo sur les réunions sur
quoi j'ai directement proposé ça à
ludovic et julien et je regrette
absolument pas parce que ça a été le
tournage le plus marrant de toute ma vie
ne vraiment pas celle apprennent à se
taper fous rires sur fous rires je les
48 heures à las vegas pas pour les
biatch et le poker mais pour le cs le
salon des nouvelles technologies c'est
vraiment un endroit de dingue
le geek qui était en moi était
totalement comblé du magazine respect
mag nous a demandé de faire la
couverture avec norman alors c'était
vraiment super de rencontrer l'équipe ça
super magazine gratuit en plus cette
thématique du respect c'est super
intéressant et je porte un noeud
papillon n'est pas de donner d'autant
plus j'ai participé dans la même semaine
à deux tournages le thriller du before
avec jérôme et luigi clash mario avec
hugo c'était la semaine embrasse tes
potes on verra ça ça arrive d'ailleurs
les filles si vous aimez bien jérôme il
embrasse très mal hein
par contre hugo j'ai fait une parodie de
la photo la plus réduite et du monde 3
millions d'euros tweet c'est un score
pas mal c'est vrai et il s'avère que mon
tweet a été le plus redouté de france en
2014 ça fait extrêmement plaisir
j'aimerais remercier ben mon agent mon
producteur bref toutes les personnes qui
n'existe pas j'ai dépassé les 5 millions
d'abonnés
ça m'a énormément touché c'est vraiment
un truc de fou et pour vous remercier
j'ai répondu à vos questions ta réaction
qu'on a eu 5 millions d'abonnés
wattez millions tu fais moins brouillée
hockey w9 a organisé une remise des prix
des vidéos d'humour sur internet et je
suis reparti avec deux prix voilà ça me
fait très plaisir
ils sont en plastique et c'était aussi
l'occasion de ma vie et classe puisque
j'ai porté un autre forme de 55 cm fait
sur mesure pour pécho en boîte c'est
c'est le mieux moi je connais pas mieux
c'est parti alors je sais une émission
de télé qui remet des prix pour internet
un petit peu du foutage de gueule mais
j'ai pu rencontrer rémy gaillard voilà
c'était super important pour moi parce
que c'est un petit peu mon idole et
j'étais un pogo avec lui et anthony
kavanagh et je me suis foulé la cheville
du coup deux semaines de béquilles super
soirée vraiment j'ai été l'invité du
grand journal à côté d'une de mes idoles
aaron paul de la série breaking bad
c'est ma série préférée
voilà tout simplement du coup j'étais
vraiment comme un gamin en plus il est
super sympa on a discuté genre 8
secondes c'était cool
la boutique en ligne de t-shirts a fêté
son premier anniversaire c'est c'est
super important pour moi parce que le
dessin ça fait vraiment partie de ma vie
quand j'étais gamin je vais devenir
dessinateur et j'adore fermé visuels de
a à z et ensuite est portée au seul
hasard je fais une vidéo pour la promo
du film x men avec julien on est allé à
londres pour tourner avec hugh jackman
c'était vraiment un truc de ouf j'ai
encore quand on m'a dit que l'on pouvait
avoir lieu jackman dans notre vidéo
j ai pas cru jusqu'à ce que je me
retrouve devant lui je pensais vraiment
qu'il allait annuler ou décalés ou alors
faire totalement autre chose mais ne pas
être là et finalement été là il avait
une bonne humeur et une énergie vraiment
incroyable c'était vraiment mortel ce
tournage moi c'est vraiment dingue en
tant que youtube heures va de me
retrouver avec des gens d'hollywood
c'est un truc de ouf avec julien ludovic
ont enfin pu s'empêcher de faire les
réunions deux et on s'était dit viens
pour la blague on demande à dany boon de
faire une apparition j'aurais va venir
et il est venu voilà c'était vraiment
marrant de tourner avec lui et après on
s'est dit viens on donne
jessica alba de faire une apparition et
on attend on est en attente d'une
direction los angeles pour l'e3 le plus
grand salon des jeux vidéo sur la
planète terre c'est vraiment le paradis
des gamers c'est la deuxième année je
vais là-bas c'est vraiment super j'ai pu
faire plein de vidéos pour ma chaîne
sport gaming c'était vraiment fun et
j'ai pu croiser omar sy qui est l'homme
les plus sympas du monde
on m'a invité à l'émission fort boyard
c'est vraiment un rêve de gosse
j'adorais cette émission quand j'étais
gamin j'ai pu y aller avec mes potes
maxime et jérôme on s'est éclaté j'ai
adoré peut prendre des lombrics sous le
visage vraiment un super moment j'y
retourne quand ils veulent et s'ils
veulent pas j'y retourne quand même je
prends un bateau je m'en bats les steaks
je grimpe comme ça avec squeeze on a
animé le cipriani de lynch ou un
spectacle au grand rex avec 2500
personnes retransmis sur youtube
c'était vraiment que c'était vraiment
super enrichissant c'était vraiment une
super expérience
parce que tenir deux heures sur scène ça
n'a rien à voir avec dix minutes en
vidéo
du coup on a pris vraiment plein de
trucs mon moment préféré c'est bien sûr
la petite surprise quand toute la salle
a trouvé un pistolet nerv caché sous son
siège est à visée squeeze leurs 2500
fléché dans la gueule ça fait pas du
bien alors j'ai vraiment vécu plein de
tout du ouf est la chaîne syrienne et
lindsay tanner la violoniste clean c'est
staline qui est passé nous voir le
supplanter en jet-ski film parodie des
sims un top 10 en or à un live avec les
joueurs du psg dont david luiz bref avec
cette chaîne ont fait vraiment tout le
temps n'importe quoi et ça ça me fait
extrêmement plaisir grosse fierté pour
moi d'avoir été choisi pour être dans la
campagne d'affichage de youtube dans les
rues de paris ça fait vraiment bizarre
d'avoir sa tête en énorme sur une
affiche et j'ai pu rencontrer robert
king seul le patron de youtube on est
directement devenus potes il ya une
sorte de complicité qui s'est créée
c'est devenu parano fils bref non ça
c'est pareil 6 millions d'abonnés
voilà je sais même pas quoi dire pour
vous remercier pour ce que j'ai fait
c'est que vous et livrer quelques
anecdotes sur moi que vous ne connaissez
pas j'adore quand on me masse le crâne
mais vrai
dès qu'on me touche la tête même le
visage ça m'endort immédiate la chaîne
de télé gulli a récompensé les artistes
préférés des jeunes et j'ai gagné le
prix du web comiques préférés voilà
c'est un prix en mousse pas mal enfin le
magazine science et vie junior mon
magazine préféré quand j'étais gamin m'a
demandé de faire une coupe
j'ai accepté dans la seconde alors ça se
voit pas mais j'étais super content oui
je suis content comme ça
après les affiches dans paris youtube a
invité dans le youtube rewind c'est le
mix des vidéos buzz de l'année en
musique j'ai adoré le tournage c'était à
londres j'ai rencontré plein de youtuber
géniaux qui venait de d'angleterre
d'allemagne et ça vous parle peut-être
pas beaucoup mais pour moi ça ça me
touche énormément parce que c'est un
petit peu un accomplissement conclut
tube heures voilà y ait ce troisième
voyage aux etats unis cette année cette
fois ci c'était pour faire une surprise
à mister vie lui faire rencontrer son
idole tony parker
j'ai vraiment adoré ce voyage parce que
ça a mis plein d'étoilés dans les yeux
de mr vie et ça fait toujours plaisir de
faire plaisir à un pote simplement et
l'année se termine sur un projet je vous
dévoile maintenant je suis en train de
tourner un court-métrage que j'ai écrit
alors c'est tout nouveau pour moi c'est
une vidéo beaucoup plus longue que
d'habitude
j'incarne un nouveau personnage on n'a
rien à voir avec mes autres vidéos et
j'aime bien changer
j'aime bien tester des nouveaux trucs
c'est ça que j'aime bien avec internet
c'est que finalement on peut faire ce
qu'on veut et bien faire tout le temps
la même chose
j'espère que vous apprécierez ça sort en
janvier et pour finir je voulais tout
simplement vous remercier parce que tout
ce que je vis et c'est grâce à vous si
si je peux vivre mais
voilà des rêves de gamin c'est grâce à
vos clics comme ça elle me suivre sur
mes vidéos ça me fait énormément plaisir
donc encore merci j'espère que j'ai
passé une bonne et 2014 et j'espère que
2015 sera encore meilleure a très vite
ouais c'est pas parce qu en fait moi je
voudrais marc bonnet à la chaîne comme
on fait et ba s'est parfaitement
gratuite j'ai cliqué avec ton doigt
d'accord mais je vais le faire voilà
fait l'océan
c'est une très bonne idée je suis
content de te rencontrer aussi qu'alors
janot à aller un verre d'eau c'est du
lourd pain